Speaker 1: Let's go next to.
Why don't we speak to Thomas from
Massachusetts? Thomas, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me? Yes, I can. All right,
so first of all, I hear you're from Mars as well,
so from your fellow Massachusetts senator.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I grew up in Massachusetts.
I'm actually from Argentina now in New York,
but I'm intimately familiar with Massachusetts.
Speaker 4: So my question is, usually during
midterms, the incumbent political party
loses seats. Yes. And as we know, even with a slim
majority, Republicans are already bottlenecking
legislation. So my main concern is making sure
we win the House and Senate in the midterms.
Speaker 1: So. So hold on a second. Look, I'm I'm
I'm not even sure that. So with a slim majority
of Republicans don't have a split. The
Republicans are in the minority now
and Democrats control the House and Senate. Are
you saying you want Democrats to retain control
in the fall? I just want to make sure we're on the
same page as to what the situation is right now.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was more referring to the
Senate. I like only Kamala Harris is giving us
the advantage. Yeah, I want more control.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. Got it.
Speaker 4: So I was thinking, do you think we
should go like the milk toast center left out
of just trying to unify everyone or take the
more progressive left stance to get more people
Speaker 1: taking taking the milquetoast center
left approach won't unify everyone? I think
that that's the mistake. It's not it will it
will lead to this. The center and the right
will call center left extreme leftism and then the
progressive and further left will call center left
Republicanism. And I think it's just there's
no evidence whatsoever that doing that is
actually going to help anybody on the left.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was a very pretty girl,
more laughter, so I just wanted
to get your verification on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I know I would. I mean,
I think what makes sense is you figure out
what the national platform is going to be and
then you figure out how to win races in the
different states in which you're running. And
it may be different to win a race in Florida
than to win a race in Washington state
as a Democrat. And I think it's OK to
run the races differently in different states.
Speaker 4: OK, that's all I need. All right,
thanks, Thomas, appreciate it.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much.
Let's take a very quick break. And
then if you're holding, don't hang up,
because I'm going to go right back
to the phones in just a second.